last week i mentioned this idea about
everyone having secrets they don't want
out there in the world
from that perspective it made sense that
even our murder victim aaron might have
them
which in episode 4 we found out she did
and it all kind of really shines the
spotlight on there being a connection
between what happened to her
and katy bailey when that was looking
pretty thin
based on their lifestyles perhaps we
haven't yet scratched the surface of
what that connection means for what's
really going on in east town
hey guys pete here today i'll be
breaking down mayor of east town episode
4
or i guess when you're really feeling
pissed marianne of east town
this video will contain spoilers if you
haven't watched the episode yet this is
your chance to leave
also before we dive in over the past
couple of episodes
the show's been putting out pretty
revealing trailers for the upcoming
episode
so this week what i'm gonna do is i've
been wanting to do some theory videos
anyway so i'll follow this recap up with
the second video talking about the
trailer
and ideas about what's going on in the
series overall
with that out of the way let's get into
it because there's a lot we have to
cover
so we start off with mare in bed she's
still reeling from being suspended
she hasn't told everyone yet and there's
this great shot where she gets up out of
bed
sort of walks around in a circle and
doesn't know what to do with herself
she goes to talk things over with lori
news is already spreading around town
that she isn't working anymore and it's
worth mentioning that she has a really
solid friend here that knows her
accepts her as she is and supports her
when she's down
their connection feels crucial and i
would guess that mare will rely on this
and need this before all is said and
done
lori tells her that it's probably a good
idea to step away from things
she's pretty much saying this knowing
that her friend won't do it but she
still has to suggest it
and at least she learns that mare will
be going to therapy and can support her
in that
at the police station colin shows up
bearing wawa coffee
and learns that mare's been taken off
the case we meet this new detective
houser who's going to take her place
he kind of seems like a jerk and we
learned that the dna results came back
and neither dylan or frank are dj's
father
at the hospital we find out that dylan
knows this he's upset that his parents
are still
caring for dj and even though he's been
a pretty awful character
later when we see dj screaming in the
middle of the night and they sort of
have this fake out where he walks over
with the pillow and you think for a
second he might actually smother the
child
instead he picks him up which is
somewhat reassuring since dj's situation
is in limbo with aaron dead and her
father in jail someone's gonna have to
take care of him
the other big reveal is that dawn is
actually taking care of katie's daughter
kenzie this is the first we've seen of
that
and she does get this call saying that
katie's alive
and wants to come home and the caller
wants five thousand dollars
this is incredibly suspicious and we see
that through
beth later when she says that it's
obviously a scam
but it also makes sense that dawn would
want to find out what's going on here
i suppose in a sprawling mystery in a
situation that everyone might be a
suspect
it's natural that some parts of the
story feel less essential than others
based on where your head's at
dawn's situation didn't have me on the
edge of my seat but we do see her
struggling with the idea of maybe
stealing the money from her work
eventually when she gets the call she
doesn't actually take any money with her
she just chops up a bunch of the missing
posters puts them in a drop bag
brings a gun along and the plan appears
to be that she'll try to overpower the
person
in hopes of finding out where katie is
but in the end it all turns out to be a
hoax it was actually freddy that was
making the call
that makes an awful situation even worse
for her because obviously she's close
with beth
so she can't even tell someone who's
clearly supportive of her what happened
because her strung out brother did it
and we've seen that he's already making
beth's life
stressful in this episode we also found
out that he overdosed and that he's
staying at her house again
i guess the one thing this does is it
takes freddie out of the running for
being a suspect
although he wouldn't have been very high
on my list in the first place
and i guess it just reinforces how
connected everyone in this small town
is and how that makes everything pretty
complicated
not so much a reveal but more of a
confirmation that deacon mark was let go
from the last place he was at
under allegations of sexual misconduct
with a 14 year old girl
colin goes to find him ask him about it
he's defensive as you would be
either way but it does seem like he's
probably hiding something here
i mean wouldn't you learn your lesson if
you just got into that kind of situation
and maybe not become friends and give
your phone number out to aaron
there isn't enough here yet to say
what's going on colin does bring up the
idea that hey this is gonna get out
there if i know about it
other people are gonna find out and
that's gonna go badly for him
and later in the episode we see that
father dan did get a call from a
reporter about him
they're gonna be writing an article
there's a tense discussion
where mark just says that he told him
everything there was to know
and perhaps the problem is now that he
doesn't believe him anymore
to her credit after her really bad
decision to try to use her power to ruin
somebody's life mare does come clean to
her family
helen freaks out for all of us basically
but in the end they don't seem all that
surprised that she did something like
that
also to her credit she does go and see
the therapist when she comes in she does
a lot of talking almost like she's
trying to control the situation
tells her hey i don't want you to get
let down if nothing happens
because i've been through this before
and i'm not expecting anything to come
of it
she doesn't believe it will help and i
guess my takeaway from this was that the
therapist actually seems pretty good
pretty well equipped in the situation
which means probably something will come
out of it she will have a breakthrough
because let's face it mare needs it one
final thing before we get into the big
stuff that happened
and that was that we saw mayor looking
at aaron's social media
she hasn't stopped looking into the case
she's still thinking about what happened
she watches a video of her talking about
being exhausted from being a mother
and then mare has this memory of kevin
and carrie when they were in full blown
addiction
and this terrible episode where he's
laying into his mother
carey's backing him up surprisingly
mayor is not really
fighting back which is kind of revealing
in how she's dealing with him compared
to how she deals with everyone else
but it's not terribly surprising we'd
learned that they were addicts we'd
learned that kevin hated mayor
we hear him say it here and once again
we see that carrie was right there by
his side
this doesn't absolve mare for what she
did but it does make it a little easier
to understand how she arrived at the
decision to do so
and there's a similarity here to what
beth is dealing with with
freddy and how difficult addiction is
for families
we also see carrie have her first
overnight with drew at her new place
she eventually has to give in and bring
him back because he couldn't sleep
we see her break down and tell mayor
that she knows that she set her up we
already knew that
she tells her that she's trying really
hard to get her life together
and asked her to just stop after that we
see a girl we don't know
riding in a van with a man that we're
not supposed to be able to tell who
he is she's a prostitute she looks like
she's a teenager maybe early 20s
and when she starts to get undressed she
notices that the man isn't doing the
same which prompts her to ask
is this your first time and instead of
answering he reaches out and grabs her
around the neck
as mentioned we're definitely not
supposed to be able to tell who he is
we can see that he's white we can see
that he has short dark hair
which makes it almost look like it might
be deacon mark but later when we
see him take her into benny's tavern
which looks like it's not open anymore
he throws her into a locked room with a
mattress on the floor
and to me he looks kind of big which
means he doesn't really match any of the
people who i thought might be possible
candidates she starts to scream and
katie bailey
who's also locked in there alive tells
her that no one can hear her
so now we know what happened to katie we
don't get a great look at what's going
on in there but it does look like she's
probably
been there the whole time and everything
about this room
screams sex slave to me i can't think of
any other good reason why this guy would
lock up
young girls he meets on an escort
website other than he's using them for
sex
speaking of the escort website we learn
all about side door
when mayor goes over to colin's house to
talk about the case
before she gets there we see colin at
home with his mother
it's a little strange i mean she seems
like a piece of work
and i guess the implication is that he
still lives with her
otherwise i don't know what she's doing
there once they start talking the case
we learned that missy sager was a good
student
and athlete who had an accident got on
painkillers that escalated from
pills to heroin and she wound up an
escort on side door to help feed her
habit
detective houser mayor's replacement
doesn't think the cases are related
missy and katie maybe but not with aaron
and before we met missy
i was starting to wonder if katie and
aaron's cases were connected
so i can see where they're coming from
because aaron is just in a different
situation than katie bailey was
however mare's not convinced that aaron
doesn't have some secrets she says she
knows teenage girls are sneaky
so the fact that they haven't been
turning up any evidence that she turned
to prostitution
isn't really sealing the deal because
she says with a father like kenny that
there's no way that she would have
pictures like that on her own computer
that leads them to go to talk to jess
who for all intents and purposes
seems to be helpful and cooperative she
explains that aaron lied about dylan
being the father
because she liked dylan's parents and
that she wanted dj to have something
like that in his life
after some pressing they find out that
aaron did create a side door account at
jess's place
but even so she feels confident that she
never actually met someone like she
could never go through with it
after they go downstairs but before they
leave mayor goes back
upstairs to ask jess about aaron's
journals
to me this seems like she's trying to
keep some of the details to herself
and i'm not really sure where that's
headed but she does lie about why she
went back upstairs
and of course later in the episode when
we see her go looking
she doesn't tell the police that she's
going there or
call in anything about this clue jess
did seem to be cooperative but i thought
she looked a little suspicious when she
asked about the journals
i'm not sure that that was the intention
but we do see her watch them leave
through her window
with a look on her face that says that
she didn't tell them
everything another spot where a look on
a character's face hinted that there was
something more important going on
was when we saw lori and john at home
watching the news when their son came
in and asked what they were saying the
camera lingered on him in a way that you
couldn't miss
i have no idea what that's about but
he's a suspect for having a secret at
least after that
a couple other things worth mentioning
helen hiding her ice cream in the frozen
veggies bag was pretty hilarious
for the most part all the family stuff
is still working and funny and it's a
good way to lighten things up
the siobhan girlfriend stuff kinda lands
even below the dawn story for me
i imagine there's gonna be a payoff to
it and both stories are fine on their
own but i do find myself having less
interest in comparison to everything
else that's going on
personally i never thought siobhan and
becca were involved in aaron's killing
but there were some people who had her
as their top suspect
i think the thing with becca in this
episode kind of shuts the door on that
and the new girlfriend seems to be there
to help her get a different perspective
on her family situation
the necklace that mare found inside the
dresser in aaron's room is really
curious
the date says 5 29 17. dj's only a year
old so that's probably not supposed to
be his birthday
on the other hand drew and kenzie are
both about 4 years old but why would she
have a necklace with one of their
birthdays on it it could have something
to do with her mother since she's not
around anymore
maybe it's the day that she passed away
or something like that
but i'm gonna have to think about this
more and come back to it in the next
video none of the answers i'm coming up
with at this point are really making
sense finally colin made his move he
asked mayor out on the same night where
richard had already asked her to go out
for his birthday
turns out that lady hawk finds herself
pretty popular with this sudden influx
of new men in town
this is not the development i was hoping
for but it is kind of fun to watch
he is a detective like her dad he's got
that going for him and while richard has
been
pretty nice overall in the last couple
of episodes
he probably lost some key points at that
book party he invited her to
although i mean do you really hire an
actor like guy pierce just to have him
come to town to get tossed
aside there's definitely something going
on with the character
and at least from what she said to helen
it looks like it's a toss-up at this
point she doesn't know which one she's
feeling more
overall not my favorite episode of the
run but still a good episode of tv
some of the story lines feel less
essential time will tell on that but the
twists and reveals were all pretty
exciting
there are seven episodes total so we're
officially past the halfway point
the pace doesn't seem to be letting up
that's a good sign
we're getting a steady stream of reveals
that help balance out all the added
mysteries that pop
up and now we just have to wait to see
how it plays out
these lingering camera shots that exist
to draw suspicion on characters we saw
this with billy and fey
in the early episodes they're probably
not all leading
somewhere but i do feel like it's time
for some of them to start paying off
it's a useful technique but you can't
just keep pulling it out if it never
leads anywhere
not much frank at all in this episode
except that we found out he wasn't the
father
and the show didn't really back off in
the effort to make deacon mark look
shady
even though it still doesn't feel likely
that he's the actual killer
for what it's worth i think the guy
holding katie and missy is a new
character we haven't met yet
there's a chance that we could get some
insight into who he
is through the side door website mayor
did tell
colin to contact its owners i said at
the beginning that we might not
understand why this connection between
katie and aaron is important this guy
seems to hold the girls he finds on the
website hostage in his sex dungeon
that wouldn't implicate him in what
happened to aaron at all
in fact it makes it feel unlikely that
he had anything to do with what happened
to her
i'm left thinking that whether she met
someone on the site or not
its existence shows that there's
definitely a market for young women to
make money through hooking up with older
men
in this town it's popular enough that
her as a regular high school girl for
all intents and purposes knew about it
and that her friend was willing to help
her set up an account to me that makes
me wonder about all the adult men
that we've met in the show pretty much
any of them could have been using the
website
she did use a fake name but anyone that
knew her would recognize her if they
went on there
and come on the whole premise of this
show is that everyone knows everyone
else i think that's a good place to
leave things let's pick up the
conversation in the comments
tell me your theories and what's on your
mind after the episode
in the next few days i'll follow this up
i'll put out another video talking about
the trailer there's a lot going on in
that
plus i'll get into my theories along
with some of the other interesting ones
that are out there
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon